with this kind of weather you might tap
into your rainy day fund or what clark
county credit union calls their
bonus dividend payment rocky spoke with
the credit union to find out more
so we're starting off the new year
talking about clark county credit union
and
what is happy bonus dividend day explain
that
absolutely since 2001 clark county
credit news
been able to give back over 68 million
dollars to our members
that's real money that goes into our
members accounts it's great
and uh yeah so every single member is
going to get
at least twenty dollars in their account
regardless of uh
if they only have fifty dollars in their
savings account they're still going to
get
twenty dollars in that account uh so you
think about when was the last time your
bank
gave you 20 on a 50 deposit
now we had to stop this a few years ago
during the great the recession but we
were able to bring it back seven years
ago and we've been going strong
ever since right up through this year
even with a pandemic so this year we're
able to get back 1.5 million
we weren't sure that we were going to be
able to do a bonus dividend this year
when the pandemic hit our primary focus
was to make sure that we were
financially stable
so we could help support our members
through this pandemic but in 2020 we
wanted to help
as many members as possible especially
those who were
financially hit by this pandemic so we
offered what
was auto skip pays for our members
and we were able to approve over 2 800
auto skip pays which meant
that our members didn't have to pay more
than 4 million dollars
in loan payments while they were going
through this hardship okay so let's talk
about now how people can actually
spend this dividend day or what they
should do with the bonus
absolutely of course members are free to
do whatever they want with their bonus
dividends some people
use the money to pay down some debt some
will use it for a rainy day
fund some people just have a little bit
of fun with it it really depends on how
much you're going to get back
some people will get hundreds some
people will get thousands
in those cases it's a good opportunity
to pay off some debt
or set it away for an emergency fund an
emergency fund is one of the best tools
you'll ever have to help get you through
a financial disaster
especially in times when regular income
is not coming in
that emergency fund can help get you
through that period
so we recommend that people save up
enough to have at least four a month's
reserve of expenses
and don't make it overwhelming or
intimidating when you first start start
with what you can build up two weeks
of expenses then build it up to a month
and if no unforeseen
events happen where you have to dip into
that money let it build up to two months
in three months
until you're comfortable with the amount
of money you have set aside for a rainy
day so i had been a member of the credit
union for almost 27 years
and one year this worked out great our
sink was going out the faucets were
going out we had to replace the whole
sink
and it just happened to be just before
that bonus dividend was paid so the
bonus dividend actually put in our new
sync and
how can people become members of the
clark county credit union so they can
participate in next year's bonus
dividend you can actually start your
account online and we'll have
a new account specialist walk you
through the whole process
and then once you're a member you're
free to come in and use any of our full
service branches they're throughout the
valley
for more information or to become a
member of the clark county credit union
call 702-228-2228